holding her own head aloft blood
streaming into her mouth and those of
her female followers feet planted on a
copulating couple chinamasta is an
audacious incarnation of divine feminine
energy
a buddhist and hindu tantric goddess her
name translates from sanskrit to she who
is decapitated but while chopping off
your own head seems like a pretty
decisive move chinemasta is in fact a
goddess of contradictions one who
balances a fine line between giving and
receiving self-preservation and
sacrifice reproduction and death
[Music]
as a tantric goddess chinemaster rears
her distinctive head across a range of
cultures and scriptures
tantra an intricate system of beliefs
and practices that originated in india
in the middle of the first millennium is
practiced by both hindus and buddhists
tantric rituals include the use of
mantras meditation coded language and
deliberative gestures they are intended
to channel enlightenment through the
physical body the hindu tantric
tradition celebrates the divine mother
devi or shakti as a supreme deity who
comes in many different manifestations
from the demon slayer durga to the
golden kamala grantor of peace
the dasha maha vidyas or great wisdoms
are 10 interrelated forms of shakti
whose purpose is to extend human
awareness beyond regular levels of
perception guiding their worshipers
towards fundamental truths chitimasta is
the sixth of these wisdom deities a
fearsome figure who can transcend the
limits of the mind
there are numerous origin stories for
chinemasta but many involve a
combination of sex hunger and radical
sacrifice in the prana toshini tantra a
collection of hindu tantric texts the
gentle incarnation of shakti parvati was
bathing outside with two attendants
without warning she became so aroused
that she turned black and yet her two
hungry attendants wouldn't stop
pestering her for food they were so
unrelenting that parvati performed a
scandalous act she sliced her head off
with her razor sharp fingernails
assuming the form of chinamasta the
decapitated goddess blood gushed from
her neck and poured into the mouths of
her attendants her severed head catching
the blood in her still-living mouth in
another story from this collection
parvati and shiva were having an
intimate moment but no sooner had their
passions abated then here come those two
attendants again begging for food once
again parvati severed her head to
nourish them and take the form of
chinemasta in these versions of the
story hunger and sexual desire are
intertwined both appear to sap human
energy but chinemasta transforms these
cravings into the source of power
buddhist tantric texts name the
decapitated goddess as chinamunda and
there are subtle differences between the
two but scholars generally agree that
chinemasta and cinemunda are the same
goddess ones also known by a thousand
plus names in tantric scripture
in buddhist tantrism chinamunda is a
form of the supreme goddess vadra yogini
a goddess who embodies passion and love
without ego buddhist texts do not
explain the origin of chinamunda but
there are several manifestations of the
goddess who slice off their heads
including two sisters and a princess who
can decapitate themselves at will to
prove their divinity to those who doubt
them as chinamunda vajrayogini displays
her supreme yogic ability and her
unattachment to ego whatever name she is
going by it's important to note that the
decapitated goddess is always able to
place her head back on her body at will
indicating her defiance of death and
powers of renewal across all texts the
goddess is depicted with red or orange
skin naked save for her jewels a garland
of skulls and a snake coiled around her
waist the skulls stand for her ability
to transcend the passage of time and the
fear of death
while the snake as a symbol of
immortality cements her everlasting life
her lavish jewelry is also rich with
symbolism with her five mudras or
ornaments symbolizing the five virtues
of giving morality patience perseverance
and meditation chinemasta's body itself
stands for a sixth virtue progna or
insight her third eye reinforces her
possession of a deeper form of knowledge
as well as her balanced perspective on
past present and future it's rare for
chinamasta to look directly at her
devotees
rather by looking unflinchingly back at
her severed body she directs her
followers to scrutinize themselves
it would take a lot more than a bit of
introspection to make chinemasta flinch
as suggested by her wielding of a bloody
sacrificial knife and her warrior's
stance
with one foot advancing in front of the
other she stands poised to defend her
followers and to destroy the forces of
ignorance
chinemasta certainly cuts a shocking
figure but while blood is more commonly
associated with the demonic in this case
it also functions as a vital and
life-giving substance by spilling her
own blood and feeding it to her
followers chinamasta actively converts
bloodshed usually a symbol of draining
life into a life force
but the question remains who benefits
from this life force
is chinemasta's self-beheading an act of
castration that dilutes her powers by
decapitating herself does she not make
the ultimate sacrifice for her
materially and spiritually hungry
attendance
decapitation is a common trope in indian
mythology which is typically inflicted
as a punishment or an act of
self-annihilation
on the surface a beheading seems like a
pretty fast way to lose your agency but
if we look a little more closely
characters who meet this fate are often
transformed into something greater than
themselves while losing your head is
undoubtedly a violent occurrence it
could also be about severing the ego and
transcending earthly circumstances for
the sake of enlightenment
similarly chinemasta appears to give
herself up to the needs of her
attendants who pester her mercilessly
for food even when she's busy in some
texts their incessant demands cause her
to turn her attention away from her own
arousal and satisfaction and to redirect
her energy towards fulfilling their
needs if we understand giving and
receiving as fundamentally opposed acts
then sure
maybe it's giving up a lot to chop off
your head and let your blood flow freely
just to please your friends but
chinemasta is also gaining something in
the process by cutting off her head she
liberates herself from the perils of the
mind like egotism self-delusion and
toxic thought cycles this allows her to
become more present and powerful in her
body which in tantric teachings is seen
as the most important instrument of
spiritual enlightenment in this framing
nourishment sexual fulfillment and
spiritual enlightenment are not entities
to be found outside of oneself instead
chinemasta summons the power to satiate
herself thus we can view her shocking
act as one of self-preservation not
sacrifice
at the same time this does not mean that
this is a selfish spiritual quest again
she's a goddess who encourages us to
think beyond all binaries so buckle up
although chinemasta has transcended all
limitations her spiritual perfection
comes from her freedom to help and
nourish those who are still on their
journeys
although her attendants have their heads
intact signaling their relative
inferiority the goddess's lack of ego
gives her the capacity to aid all other
beings as she merges the role of giver
and receiver sacrificer and sacrificee
subject and object she shatters the
illusion of duality itself and reveals
the interconnection of all living things
for this goddess even death and life are
not really separate as the iconography
of her active fertile body overlaid with
deathly and violent imagery suggests
chinemasta experiences both at once and
therefore outstrips earthly limitations
chinemasta's highly paradoxical position
is associated with both destruction and
reproduction in buddhist tantric
depictions she is usually planted on
kali a personification of time and death
indicating the goddess's capacity to
vanquish these forces in hindu tantric
depictions she is shown standing upon
kama and rati the gods of love and
desire but is she trampling the famous
couple or protecting them
in some cases her position above the
couple may represent her epic
self-control just another way in which
chinamasta masters herself it could also
indicate her mastery of the cycle of
life itself with her ability to
perpetually obliterate and re-enliven
herself chinemasta becomes a powerful
symbol of reproduction to rival the
entwined couple
another reading might focus on the
imagery of the lotus flower and inverted
triangle that often appear in these
depictions
these signs associate chinemasta with
fertility abundant sexual energy and the
divine feminine while the rest of the
picture keeps her bodily autonomy at the
forefront chinemasta's yantra or
geometric diagram that acknowledges her
presence and guides meditation on the
goddess also conjures the divine
feminine with its womb-like imagery
after drawing the symbol tantric
scripture instructs worshipers to offer
flowers food ornaments and more to the
goddess they also recite suitable
mantras while meditating and performing
specific gestures while these rituals
and their meanings survive chinemasta is
not considered a prominent tantric deity
today shrines dedicated to the goddess
are rare but chinemasta surfaces in many
hindu and buddhist paintings and
practices during the hindu festival of
kali puja which celebrates kali one
neighborhood in the indian city of qatak
celebrates the goddess via the
veneration of chinamaster
while many across india celebrate
chinemasta jayanti the goddess's
designated day by engaging in rituals to
eliminate negativity and longing
as a figure who nourishes herself while
being consumed by others who fulfills
herself as she gives herself away and
who embraces destruction even as she
vanquishes death chinemasta is a goddess
who dispels duality and although
self-decapitation is her signature act
this doesn't mean that she leaves her
body behind instead chinemasta shows us
that we can nourish our physical bodies
and free our minds and that these
processes are eternally intertwined
if you love the outdoors we think you'll
really enjoy the newest digital series
from pbs called america outdoors
understory hosted by baratunde thurston
the show explores our passionate yet
complex relationship with the natural
world along the way you get to meet
everyone from surfing scientists to
fossil hunters there's a link in the
description we hope you go check it out
and then maybe go get some fresh air
you